[Music]
this week's news is all about cinemacon
in Las Vegas all the big Distributors
presented plenty of info on movies like
Kung Fu Panda 4 Spider-Man across the
spider-verse and Fast and Furious 11. in
addition to further updates on Indiana
Jones 5 Elemental and Oppenheimer there
were also new images for Mission
Impossible 7 Dune 2 and a release date
for the third season of The Witcher
enjoy our extra-long Kino Czech news
cinemacon is one of the most important
movie events of the year in major film
Distributors love to use it to promote
their upcoming movies Sony kicked things
off on the first day of the convention
in Las Vegas by revealing a lot about
upcoming projects like Spider-Man across
the spider-verse Craven the hunter Bad
Boys 4 and many more one of the most
surprising pieces of news at cinemacon
was the very first trailer for the
upcoming Gran Turismo film adaptation
the game is one of the most popular
racing franchises and can regularly
score points with its almost
photorealistic graphics and
uncompromising realism the movie tells
the story of professional racing driver
Jan martinborough will get to see
stranger things Star David Harbor as
well as Orlando Bloom in the leading
roles a worldwide release of the so far
exclusive trailer can be anticipated
soon the Spider-Man across the
spider-verse panel at cinemacon went
down particularly well with attendees as
Sony showed a full 14 minutes from the
upcoming animated Blockbuster together
with his girlfriend Gwen Stacy and many
other Spider-Man the teenager will have
to take on the super villain the spot
this time the ambitious animated film
from Sony which is to include a total of
six different animation Styles will be
released in cinemas starting June 2nd
2023 fans of the bad boys franchise with
Will Smith and Martin Lawrence got their
money's worth at cinemacon after his
scandal at the Oscars in 2022 Bad Boys 4
is Smith's first big project in time
many even suspected that he would no
longer assume a major role in the future
this does not seem to be the case
however the two main actors announced
via video message that they have already
spent four weeks in production it is
still unclear when exactly the movie
will be shown in theaters but given the
current state of production a release in
2024 seems quite likely things got
gloomy during the presentation of Craven
the hunter at cinemacon the SSU film is
about the eponymous protagonist played
by Aaron Taylor-Johnson who was one of
Spider-Man's best known villains in the
comics the fact that the movie differs
from the always cheerful MCU films of
the competitor Disney is already evident
from the age rating of 18 years come
October 6 2023 fans will then be able to
watch the movie in theaters
at cinemacon 2023 Disney showcased
plenty of updates on upcoming films like
Indiana Jones 5 the dial of Destiny
Elemental wish and the Little Mermaid
visitors to the convention were treated
to an exclusive clip from the new and
final Indiana Jones film starring
Harrison Ford in it Indy and his
goddaughter Helena Chase antagonist
Jurgen voller played by Matt Mickelson
during the Frantic ride through the city
of Tangier the role of Phoebe Waller
Bridge seems to also perform some
spectacular stunts which results in some
amusing Roars from our hero the general
public should be able to watch the scene
by June 30th 2023 at the latest when
Indiana Jones 5 the dial of Destiny hits
theaters moreover Pixar fans were able
to take a look at the first 20 minutes
of Elemental at Cinema con here we meet
protagonist Ember as a baby as she
arrives together with her parents Bernie
and Cinder in element City you could see
parts of her life and her basic mindset
that different elements should not mix
she often helps out in her parents store
but also annoys customers from time to
time because of her temper one day when
she floods the basement during a tantrum
she meets Wade a city employee who
promptly gives her a warning for the
defective pipes at the end of the scene
Amber chases weight around town as he
tries to relay the message how exactly
all plays out and how it continues in
the plot is something we can all see
from June 16 2023 as that's when
Elemental hits theaters visitors to
cinemacon were treated to various
exclusive scenes in addition to more
footage from The Haunted Mansion for
example there was also a singing scene
from Disney's new animated film wish
with Ariana Dubose and Chris Pine an
extended scene from Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 was also shown in which
Star-Lord and Gamora share an emotional
moment without realizing that the entire
crew is actually listening as for the
Little Mermaid Melissa McCarthy was seen
for the first time singing her iconic
song horror Unfortunate Souls as the sea
witch Ursula
movie Giant Warner Brothers also took
the opportunity at cinemacon to present
new trailers for the most anticipated
projects of the coming months after the
Takeover of DC Studios by Peter Safran
and James Gunn all signs are pointing to
a fresh start at DC and so Aquaman and
the lost kingdom will be the final
Blockbuster of the dceu Warner Brothers
revealed the first trailer for the
sequel and of course lead actor and Fan
Favorite Jason Momoa was given plenty of
screen time
other scenes Aquaman is said to have
been staying in a lighthouse in Atlantis
and fighting various enemies shortly
after Black Manta portrayed by Yaya
Abdul Mateen II also has an
action-packed Face-Off with the DC
Superhero by the way the controversial
actress Amber Heard is also on screen
although they may have deliberately kept
her appearance short the last dceu film
will be released on December 20th 2023
before the new DC Universe or DCU for
short takes over even though there has
been a lot of speculation in recent
months about the first Solo movie by
Barry Allen AKA The Flash and lead actor
Ezra Miller the movie will play a
decisive role in the transition from the
old to the new DC Universe if those
present are to be believed however the
wait for the new shots was definitely
worth it and director Andy machete has
by all accounts succeeded in making a
very good superhero film whether the
final film will live up to the fans
expectations which have now been raised
even further can be seen in movie
theaters from June 16 2023 the Barbie
film adaptation by director Greta Gerwig
is likewise expected to have a lot of
potential the multi-colored adaptation
which is supposed to be much more
profound than the neon pink world and
cliched characters would have us believe
is already an internet phenomenon in
addition to Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling actor and wrestler John Cena
will play a special version of Ken in
the trailer shown at cinemacon Cena is
seen swimming through the water as a
merman while accompanied by a mermaid
played by pop star Dua Lipa the finished
movie is scheduled for release on July
21st 2023 so the Comic-Con trailer
should be out very soon the sequel to
Dennis villenev's Dune released in 2021
is surrounded by just as much hype the
film takes us back to the desert planet
arakis where the main character Paul
Atreides is preparing for his revenge
campaign against Baron harkona the
freshly shown trailer is set to live up
to the expectations for the Epic sci-fi
movie and create great anticipation for
Dune part 2. fittingly Vanity Fair
published the first exclusive use of
images from Doom 2 on Thursday in
addition to familiar characters such as
Zendaya's chani Josh Rowan scurney and
baron harkonen there is also a
mysterious shot of the back of the
herconin air Faye rauta played by
newcomer Austin Butler the new actor is
joined by Florence Pugh as Princess
erulin and Leia sedu as lady Margot for
moviegoers the movie will be a special
experience as the film was shot entirely
with IMAX cameras and will thus already
visually surpass its predecessor
starting November 3rd 2023 you'll be
able to watch Doom 2 in cinemas the
presentation of Meg II the trench also
made massive waves one scene in
particular in which lead actor Jason
Statham fights the giant shark with a
sword provides a great preview of many
crazy action scenes trailer which is not
yet public you can even see a T-Rex
being eaten by a Megalodon but there
will be no Crossover with Jurassic world
said scene probably shows a prehistoric
world and not the 21st century we look
forward to the release of the trailer
and the theatrical release on August 4th
2023.
Universal Studios did things in style
presenting some exciting sneak peeks of
their upcoming movies at cinemacon
including Kung Fu Panda 4 Fast and
Furious 11 and Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer Christopher Nolan spoke
about the unique historical significance
of the title character in his new film
Oppenheimer played by Cillian Murphy he
also hinted that a new trailer could be
expected as part of the theatrical
release of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
3. audience is at the event were already
excited about spectacular images from
the movie which were featured in a
five-minute clip Oppenheimer is set to
hit theaters on July 21st DreamWorks was
strongly represented at cinemacon 2023.
first there was some footage of Ruby
Gilman teenage Kraken and trolls 3 band
together to be seen the Highlight was
certainly the appearance of Jack Black
who had quite a bit to say about Kung Fu
Panda 4 the eponymous hero Poe meets his
most treacherous opponent ever the
chameleon badass sorcerer who can also
summon villains from the past Poe must
face each one of them personal
before that he must train somebody as a
successor since he himself is to become
the new spiritual leader of The Valley
Of Peace the film will be released on
March 8 2024 the highlight of the
Universal Pictures presentation at
cinemacon 2023 was the appearance of the
cast of The Fast and Furious franchise
after first looking back at the previous
movies Vin Diesel went on to announce
that fast X will continue with part 2
hitting theaters in 2025. first though
Fast and Furious 10 AKA fast X will be
released in cinemas on May 19 2023.
the Netflix series The Witcher with
Hollywood star Henry Cavill is without
question one of the most popular shows
on the streaming service since the end
of the second season fans have been
eagerly awaiting the third and
presumably final season featuring Henry
Cavill on the adventures of The Witcher
geralt of Rivia according to the latest
reports the season will be released in
two parts the First episodes can be
expected as early as late June when
Henry Cavill announced his exit from The
Witcher series a while ago there was
great disappointment among fans one
contentious point that led to the
departure of the lead actor was the
increasingly major discrepancies between
the book by polish author Andre
sapkowski and the Netflix series even if
The Parting of Kabul may be tough for
some fans you don't have to expect a
total cancellation of the series as of
season 4 Liam Hemsworth will take over
the lead role how that will go down with
fans remains to be seen just a few days
ago the first teaser for The Witcher
season 3 was released you can see some
epic scenes with geralt and Siri as well
as many other characters that are known
from the video games or the books the
first five episodes of season 3 will be
released on June 29th with the remaining
three episodes coming out just about a
month later on July 27th we are
definitely excited and look forward to
further information
just a few days ago the busy promo phase
of Mission Impossible dead reckoning
kicked off with the release of new
images from the film The movie is set to
hit theaters this summer and has a true
star-studded cast as the new images from
the official Twitter account
impressively approved one image for
example shows main character Ethan Hunt
strolling through Venice with his three
companions Elsa fost Benji and Luther
another picture shows Tom Cruise in his
iconic pose raising both arms
protectively in an attempt to resolve an
obviously dicey situation in the
background you can see an armored
vehicle on its way to the scene just as
typical for Tom Cruise fans are scenes
in which the actor runs away from or
towards a great danger which is often
illustrated by running scenes that last
several minutes particularly interesting
is the look at the yet to be named
antagonist who was embodied by MCU star
Palm Clement TF there is speculation
that she will work against hunt and the
IMF at least in the beginning and
possibly later switch to the side of the
good guys there is also a shot of Tom
Cruise on a motorcycle receiving
instructions from director Christopher
McCary the motorcycle scene later leads
to one of the most spectacular stunts in
the film series as was already shown in
the teaser it's safe to assume that
we'll see a lot more Daredevil Maneuvers
in the upcoming Mission Impossible 7
dead reckoning part 1. a proper trailer
should be coming out soon given that
theatrical release date of July 14 2023
this was a true Roundup of all the big
projects in the near future for more
cinemacon news that didn't make it into
the video check out our website at
tinocheck.com moreover for all the Mario
fans out there we got a video on all the
Easter eggs that you might have missed
while watching the Super Mario Brothers
movie as well as a video on a quick look
behind the scenes thanks for watching
and see you next week for more Hollywood
updates
[Music]
thank you